los objetos aquí tales son objetos que
se pueden superponer en lo que vamos a
denominar de ahora en adelante su imagen
espejo y su imagen espejo no es otra
cosa más que su imagen reflejada verdad
justamente como si estuviéramos viendo
el objeto a través del espejo muy bien y
en unos momentos les voy a mostrar que
una taza de café es un ejemplo de un
objeto aquí dado por otro lado los
objetos quirales son objetos son son
aquellos que no se pueden superponer en
sus imágenes en sus imágenes reflejadas
ahora bien la palabra girar viene de la
palabra griega de mano muy bien así que
les voy a mostrar como sus manos no se
pueden superponer una con la otra pero
su mano izquierda y de hecho también su
mano derecha son imágenes reflejadas una
de la otra vamos a echarle un vistazo a
la taza de café que está reflejada en un
espejo así que se puede ver del lado
izquierda una tasa real y en el espejo
está la imagen reflejada de esta tasa
ahora voy a sacar la taza de café para
hacer un poco de espacio y voy a poner
lo que viene el espejo que es la imagen
reflejada justo al lado
otra taza de café y esa es su imagen
reflejada y voy a tomar la taza de café
de la derecha la voy a rotar y mientras
le estoy rotando pueden ver que se puede
superponer con el objeto de la izquierda
así que la imagen reflejada se puede
superponer y esa es la definición de un
objeto akira por eso es que una taza de
café shakira ahora vamos a intentar lo
mismo con una molécula
este es el de flúor o metano y lo que
tenemos de verde son átomos de flúor y
en el espejo pueden ver la imagen
reflejada así que una vez más voy a
sacar la molécula y poner lo que vemos
en el espejo que es la imagen reflejada
junto a ella y vamos a rotar la imagen
reflejada el de la derecha vamos a
rotarlo para ver si se puede superponer
con la que tenemos en el lado izquierdo
ok entonces la vamos a tomar y mientras
pueden ver justo cuando la comenzó a
rotar ahí pueden ver que se puede
superponer con la molécula de la
izquierda mientras que la imagen
reflejada se puede superponer por eso es
que decimos que es una molécula aquí de
verdad por lo que estos en realidad son
las mismas moléculas representadas aquí
ahora veamos mis manos tengo mi mano
izquierda y en el espejo pueden observar
pueden observar mi mano derecha lo que
parece ser como mi mano derecha así que
voy a tomar mi mano izquierda y la
derecha juntas
acabamos de mostrar que son imágenes
reflejadas una de la otra y voy a tratar
de rotar mi mano derecha para ver si la
puedo superponer con la izquierda y
pueden ver aquí que tengo mis palmas
hacia arriba pero mismo
no están apuntando en la misma dirección
por lo tanto no se pueden superponer así
que voy a intentarlo de nuevo voy a
tratar de rotar las verdad pero mis
palmas no se encuentran en la misma
posición como mis pulgares verdad así
que no importa lo que haga nunca voy a
poder superponer la verdad no importa lo
que hagas no vas a poder lograrlo y
mientras que la imagen reflejada no se
puede superponer decimos que las manos
son virales ok ahora finalmente vamos a
ver un ejemplo con una molécula ok vamos
a ver el ejemplo de una molécula en este
caso el blanco es hidrógeno
el verde es flúor el rojo es bromo y el
cloro es amarillo
la molécula está a la izquierda y en el
espejo la imagen reflejada voy a quitar
la molécula y una vez más voy a dejar un
espacio y podré ver lo que viene el
espejo justo al lado ok entonces hay una
imagen reflejada así que tengo estas dos
imágenes reflejadas de cada una de la
otra verdad y tomaré la que está a la
derecha y le intentaré rotar para ver si
la puedo superponer con la que está a la
izquierda y aquí la rote un poquito
pueden observar que los rojos digamos
los átomos de bromo están en la misma
posición sin embargo el cloro y el flúor
el que es amarillo y el verde no están
en la misma posición así que no puedo
superponer las aquí voy a intentar de
nuevo rotarlo un poco y pueden ver que
el amarillo está en la misma posición el
cloro y el hidrógeno también pero el
rojo y el verde no están verdad el rojo
y el verde no están así que no importa
cuánto gire la imagen el que está a la
derecha nunca voy a conseguir que se vea
como el de la izquierda mientras que la
imagen reflejada no se puede poner
superponer decimos que es una molécula
quiral y el carbono aquí es un carbono
muy importante con cuatro diferentes
sustituye entes ligados a él cuatro
diferentes grupos y llamaremos a este un
centro girar o un centro de quiralidad
lo que es importante remarcar es que
estos dos modelos representan moléculas
distintas